when I saw this for the first time I was
just like how did I do it's really about
doing it 100 times and you're gonna get
one of them right oh thanks lg tv for
sponsoring this video
stick around to the end and find out
more hi welcome back to another episode
of VFX artists react today we are joined
by the one only Zach king
what's up Zach Ness theme we are known
from doing a very unique style of visual
magic and visual trickery it's very hard
to figure out how Zack does it I'm
excited for this episode because I
really want to see if you guys can break
down how the magic is done well should
jump in let's do it all right
[Music]
wow that's great we wanted to reward
those who watch it for a third time oh
sorry sir it's trying you should put a
sign up or something Oh crickey Wow do
doesn't feel like it man that extra 10%
you put it the anybody you took it
another 10% so where do you think the
loop point isn't this I have a wild idea
hmm it's not actually looping until the
very end because you actually built a
set that has like three identical
corridors love that answer
we talked about really we're gonna do
that at some point because you could
have made it a square and yarn over and
over but no it's so it's not that no one
sensible spots of the loop point to be
would be when Luke wipes you so that
shrug to painting is the beginning any
wipes across you is when you'd wipe back
to the beginnings you have you got it
this stuff is so good
[Music]
oh I know this one actually this one too
when do I commitment to time we came up
with this idea like the night before the
Eclipse that is he that's really well
done
did you guys wait up there all night or
did you come back later on we came back
I think we shot that I like 4:00 p.m. or
5:00 p.m. and then came back at 8 or 9
so for this shot there's no Sun actually
there right the sun's coming from a
different right if you look at the Sun
source it's off to the right there but
it works because you guys are to the
left of the the Sun that you have on the
frame this one is really simple it's
it's a straight jump cut but there are
things you have to think about like hey
if we come back later at night like how
are you to know the spot so we're
literally like taking sticks and drawing
you know in the sand I take my shoes of
your camera screen you simply got to
make sure your hands are in the exact
same spot yeah it's just guesswork it's
really about doing it a hundred times
and you're gonna get one of them right
so obviously I'm not the first person to
come up with jump cuts and one my
favorite material to reference is
Charlie Chaplin and Buster Keaton well
these guys were doing jump cuts when it
was like actually really hard to do like
they'd have to go through you know the
frames and find the right one and they
didn't get to like play with it it was
like once they cut it was pretty much
it's like nudge it three frames to the
right yeah but there's like oh let me
get my glue so if somebody wanted to
execute a perfect match cut what tips
would you have for them it really is a
practice thing but have some your body
hold the camera go to a a position and
stand still have a person do the change
like let's say it's changing the shirt
and then you litter is it this basic you
freeze go change your shirt come back go
in the position but it's getting back to
that position like we have a little
overkill techniques where people will
come in and hold each major joint of my
body you know if your chest moves like
that's a big visual difference
especially your head too like that needs
to be in the same spot so it's literally
like it's kind of awkward but people
will come up and just kind of feel that
they're hugging you and you like wiggle
out of the position really go to the
bathroom change really quick come back
wiggle in and then they line you back up
Wow
so it's basic but it's also overkill and
complex
[Music]
okay so this one legitimately when I saw
this for the first time I was just like
how do I want to take a guess at how you
did this so there you actually have to
guess I don't know okay so I'm guessing
that there is no ladder
it's just projection mapping and it's
really really well done projection
mapping projection mapping requires you
to have a 3d track of your scene as well
as someone basic 3d reconstruction in
this scene you have a very basic plane
in another plane so your projection ends
up being really simple yeah and right as
the camera kind of like pulls back and
then locks into place right here someone
flies in a ladder and you just place so
casually and stand upon it and then
right there the ladders gone someone's
ready to pull the ladder off screen the
moment you're off the interesting theory
so here's what I'll tell you about this
one this one holds a special place in my
heart so I'm not gonna tell you how it
was done because I also want people to
guess in the comments for this one oh
yeah this one has a lot of different
theories on how it was done but I will
say that there was real paint on set
okay the parts about these videos that
are really fun to me is like how
everything is put there so quickly it's
just really about timing and again this
is one of the videos that we have to do
75 times just to get Wow
that many takes your yard Zack leave a
comment down below with your guests let
us know how you think it was done was
that do you consider yourself a magician
a magician a well I dabble in the
weekends no and like I grew up doing
magic
I loved magic I too have been known to
do the reason I don't like being called
a magician is cuz I feel like it offends
actual magicians yes because I haven't
put in the work to earn that title and
they've literally practice you know
sleight of hand or whatever stage tricks
for years I out of respect for that I'm
not but I can see why people visually
call it magic I think it made
[Music]
that's me and some of the art team
sitting up all night just just you know
acrylic paint on my clothes it's a
YouTube thumbnail the genius and a piece
of work like this is that once again the
digital effects are very straightforward
I mean you're basically just taking a
freeze-frame from right there
yeah and just tracking it back onto the
frame right you know from going
backwards in the video then likewise at
the end and that's it for like the
digital effect yeah you know it's just
really said we're cutting holes in flats
and putting up the picture frames I know
it pays off like if you do it
practically always looks better like a
lot of people could just throw up a
green screen but it has little like
there's a look to that I love the reveal
of the parallax because as the camera
moves at first like the background moves
at the same rate as you but the moment
you start moving now the background is
moving like slower yeah I call that the
extra like 15 percent extra 10 percent
we'll ask ourselves at the very end like
okay is there anything that's an extra
ten percent that we can do here maybe
it's okay the camera move or where's it
in the story where you need an extra
little beat yeah there's like little
details too that are fun like a museum
would actually still have the electrical
circuits it doesn't like that we'd print
those are just like printouts you know
like cutting out just a paper oh that's
so smart whoa okay
would you look at that five o'clock Wow
it really does fly well we're going with
a lot of work to do I need this done by
the end of the day taking that extra
step I think that's really what makes
you stand out what's your guess for this
one so I think you have a hole in the
wall you have actual post-it notes
glued to the wall there and there's just
like a little like doggy door flap but
someone else's hand is coming through
same thing with all your desk there we
have one other guy in the office who
works on her team who happens to have
the exact same looking hand as me so but
you'll notice I think he doesn't have a
ring on that's the only thing he more
picked up on it's really a matter of me
and him just knowing without him looking
the timing and so with that same take of
the hands working it also had the perf
the paper had to like he had this big
stack of papers papers that he was
chucking through the hole that most
times were getting caught how many takes
did you could take you guys to is maybe
like 35 or 40 I don't work on this one
but it was really just practicing the
hand bit and once we got that timing I
had no idea you guys worked so hard to
get so many takes and just nail it but
in a way like everything is so perfect
at the end for these short clips that it
makes sense so the guy that's filled
coffee on himself so notice yet we have
little Easter eggs running throughout
our videos all of them there's like a
back line story happening when there's
extras there was a Starbucks video that
we did it was a fake Starbucks Coffee
app we could pull the coffee out of the
phone and he's driving and he tries to
send it back through because he wants a
different coffee but it sprays all over
him so this is his probably this
actually is part three there's a part
when he's going to the office in traffic
someday you'll be able to take all of
his videos put them in order and see his
little mini movie I love that so I know
we're not exactly reacting to Hollywood
movies today but there's a lot of other
great visual Wizards out there so if
there's anybody else you would like us
to get on the show or react to their
work please leave a comment down below
it's great inspiration helps guide us
what we should do in our future episodes
[Music]
well that was smooth that was super
smooth it's it's one thing to be able to
like drop through the the shelf like
that like that's not super hard to do
but the fact that the guy comes busting
in like literally a half second after
you disappear
yeah merging that's the two things
together I would assume the bottom the
drawers just cut out you're dropping
through it but then you'd have to paint
yourself out and it's one thing to paint
yourself out but when there's people
behind you running through the door you
have to rebuild them and they're
lighting in their shadow and that's
where it gets crazy
so did you rebuild all that area
underneath there yeah we had to and I
just I almost don't believe that you had
you paid yourself out though because you
have to add the flashlight the shadows
the foot so we're the guys bust them
through the same shot as you drop it in
through the the drawer that is the
question that is the long day in
question I am gonna hazard a guess that
it is actually two different takes oh
wait prints spotted it because I feel
like it can sense a little bit that red
wedge on the top of your hair what roto
edge you might have gotten me on that
one so the hard one in this one is it
actually loops like if you're perfectly
so to do that you basically to start
here wake up grab chair throw go back to
sleep camera goes in and then everyone's
like pause so that's that's the loop
point right there oh I love that
so planar tracking is when you track
basically anything onto a flat surface
you'll see a lot of movies on the
tracking screens this would be a normal
planar track except for the fact that
the cardboard walls yeah so what would
be a simple effect something becomes
complicated because the cardboard starts
distorting and that planar track is no
longer a plane this is a manual art
someone had to go in and then morph the
image to kind of follow this cardboard
cutout I'd also imagine that this
cardboard cutout has the graphics on it
as well and you're kind of blending
between the two
dude this is a long line have you guys
been to Randy's Donuts I've never been
just seen it in so many movies but I've
never even seen it in person the line is
long I mean that's what this concept is
about we we go to show a show up in film
and the lines long and so we added that
to the concepts in the beginning that's
plastic let's get a real one fun little
easter egg it says Randy's and that's
there I'm going to guess that that's a
3d model the entire time dang I give up
I'm holding something that we had to you
know put the donut there onto it I love
the subtle touch of the roof of the
building caving in yeah getting little
bit like physics simulations in there so
another question for you once again
really subtle the people that are
reacting in the audience are those green
screen didn't elements you were the
first person to notice that so those two
guys in the picture Clinton that thing
just hopping around climbing up the wall
and you guys really remember the scene
in Inception that's rotating we
basically had a mini version of that
built the rotating room you know you've
got the room here and the camera and the
key is getting the camera to lock on you
have all this rigging to make sure that
doesn't move and so that you get the
illusion you know with the room
perspective not changing the way I
really wanted to have the people in
there was to harness them in but we had
a couple issues one insurance and safety
but also like their face within five
seconds for a super red it's off-putting
you're watching and their cheeks kind of
like often they gain weight so you shoot
one giant plate of all your actors
they're going through all the motions
and reacting to you and then a separate
plate where you are in the costume and
you do the whole move around the
everything is down I assume those
curtains those are moving in the scene
so those curtains are glued like you
cannot move them they're like completely
hard okay those little details yeah
everything is come like glued eighty
times do you miss your passion for
practical effects I love him that's like
all my favorite movies
I love the matte paintings they were
doing you know you have a scene of
Charlie Chaplin on rollerblades like
barely going down this harrowing fall
and it was really just up close they had
an image literally printed were painted
oftentimes close to the camera as your
background plate and you look at like
the perfect mix in in Jurassic Park like
because they had most of close-up shots
with the dinosaur that was real like it
sells everything else I don't know if I
would love showing up to Jurassic world
set now cuz it's like you're looking at
people in suits like it doesn't have the
same magic yeah and I think it affects
the final product oh definitely Zak
thank you for indulging us as we try to
guess and reveal the secrets you guys
did well yeah well I feel like I didn't
get anything I want to know their
guesses right I do too I want to know
other videos what you guys think how it
was done now that they've got some
insights yeah you guys have good guesses
oh I'm proud okay thank you all right so
go to your Zak's channel consider
subscribing if you haven't already you
can't wait to see you guys in the next
video hey guys we're gonna give you the
chillest brand integration we've ever
seen because Jake is really busy right
now so that's on our shoulders all right
Clint play me a tune if it's not the
pros through it we're gonna talk about
the new LG nano cell TV which is a new
TV we got in the office we're playing
Smash Brothers on it every evening which
you know that means no latency vibrant
colors and big enough picture too well
all of us and see our characters and
lifelike size so LG nano sale TVs have a
new technology in them nano technology I
guess nano cell technology it's a
multitude of things from a very thin and
nano bezel to nano filters that give you
more vibrant colors in the pixels long
story short before the
price this is one of the best images at
a television I have ever seen
I'm telling you this not because it's a
marketing point in fact that's not even
on this paper I'm telling you this other
personal experience I see a lot of
images hey I'm a visual effects artist
I appreciate beautiful imagery and this
TV is actually nice I have an old vizio
at my place and I can literally see like
the LED like cross work behind it I've
been think about upgrading and no lie
I'm probably gonna get an LG nano cell
because I've been super impressed with
how good the images at how good the
price is so if you are in the market for
a new TV go check it out you will not be
disappointed
it has our endorsement we are loving in
here at the office it's true it's true
it's true
[Music]
just watch and tell me if you guys
notice something weird I tell you guys
say anything weird
you see it are we looking at the fire
it's hard to catch catch what is there a
flicker you can say that we're getting
some frame frame duplications as you're
going free my friend